hello and welcome to the new flat so
moving in here I am having to buy all
new furniture which has been really fun
actually but I am also finding that my
priorities are maybe a little skewed in
terms of what I want to buy when for
example right now I can't stop thinking
about buying the Philips hue light bulbs
you know the really expensive ones that
connect to the Wi-Fi and you can pick
any color from your phone i Slone got a
dining table yeah I go and got anywhere
to eat and I'm thinking about that I
even went through the effort of counting
all of the light bulbs and figuring out
how much it would cost me to trick out
this entire flat with Wi-Fi lights 2100
pounds I'm not gonna do it I need to buy
somewhere to eat first
first I'm not gonna do it at all don't
do it charlie don't do it so just so
we're completely clear no it's not
product placement if it obviously it's
not if it was I'd have the light bulbs
wouldn't I I do really want the design
of this place to be as nice as I can get
it though like the amount of effort I
put into figuring out like where the
mugs we're going to go in relation to
the kettle and the teabags in the fridge
to make it so that when you make tea it
involves as little movement as possible
it's just kind of obsessive in a
worrying way really also speaking of tea
ah see that's what product placement
looks like quality mugs I'll put a link
in the description if you'd like one and
again on design obsessiveness I made the
inside of this white even though I'll be
making less money off of these because
of that because I know that when you
make tea it's easier to tell the
strengths of tea when the inside is
white so I'm really hoping my love for
tea shines through in these things I've
also revamped the design of the quality
t-shirt so that they match the mugs now
you can get one of those too and that's
the end of my sales pitch thanks for
putting up with it so my list of new
furniture that I have managed to acquire
so far are my sofa my bed and my
mattress all of which had presented
their own various problems we're both
the sofa and the bed I did decide to
assemble them by myself even though they
both clearly said in the instructions
they took two or three people to make
but I've always seen that as less of a
requirement and more of a more of a
challenge and with the mattress the poor
delivery man had to do quite a lot of
bending and squeezing to pack that thing
into the lift and get it up here the by
the time he finally did drop the thing
off in the bedroom he looked at me just
like completely exhausted and he said
whenever you get lucky on this thing
please think of me and the worst part is
that I did once and it was just briefly
but all the same thanks for the mattress
generally though my experience of living
here so far has been absolutely lovely
my favorite thing being that for some
reason in this apartment complex there
are a lot of cats just sort of roaming
free there was genuinely this one time
when I was on my way out and a little
cat followed me into the lift on my way
down and to start with I was kind of
worried I was like is this okay am I
allowed to be taking this cat down with
me but then I looked at the little guy
and he was like so chill about the whole
thing we got to the ground floor the
doors opened he just sauntered out and I
thought two things firstly that cat has
probably ridden that lifts more times
than I have he's more comfortable doing
it than me and secondly I just ridden
live of a cat how cool is that sued I've
got like three other things to talk
about but this is I am feel like I'm
already gonna cut a lot of stuff out of
this so I guess I'll see you next time
I've had a busy week that's nice anyway
goodbye
you've just had the almost imponderable
joy of watching Charlie is so cool like
which makes you like cool thank you very
much for watching here's my previous
video just in case you missed it I mean
yes at its core the video is just a list
of five films that I watched but there
is a bit more to it than that I promise
I try to do a list with a bit more depth
I'm really not selling this thing that's
fine it means you'll go in with low
expectations and then it will be really
great or you won't click on it at all
which it's also fine I can live with
that at least I tried okay bye